[Music]
obsessed with them what did you do this
about two hours ago pretty serious yeah
yeah nice thank you
turn new movie that I'm doing I play a
Parisian woman started I don't know they
wanted me to cut my hair and I come to
bed more exciting than you do I love it
I felt like you look like you just keep
my ass right now probably I would never
want to do that but don't threaten me am
i Nina Dobrev showing off a bangin new
look at the premiere of her latest movie
Flatliners it's a good day to die
[Applause]
everyone I punched today I'm gonna keep
you didn't mess around I heard you guys
went through some medical boot camp what
what did you learn
we sure did we did two maybe three weeks
of medical training later and all of the
tools that you would need to have to
resuscitate a human in a dire situation
whoo life it was obviously when we're
playing doctor something we're actually
doing it and we truly do so I don't want
to say that I'm save the life but I
could definitely keep someone alive long
enough involve the real paramedics game
now I've been asking everybody what is
one item on your career bucket list
oh wait a few actually it's not just one
I'd love to do a rom-com I'm dying to do
a period piece from this movie that I'm
doing now is gonna bucket list
speaking French in the role
yes it's a very probably the most
challenging project I've worked on so
far in my career but that's why
[Music]